une plaque commémorative pour ne jamais
oublier
à l'occasion de la journée nationale du
souvenir de la déportation
le musée de la résistance de loris rend
hommage cette année à cyprien depardieu
un résistant déporté pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale beaucoup d'émotion
surtout que c'est une journée
extraordinaire dont je me souviendrai
toute ma vie
membre du parti communiste cyprien
depardieu habiter dans cette rue
d'orléans où une plaque commémorative a
déjà été installé le militant est
arrêtée durant l'occupation allemande de
la france en septembre 1941 pour
propagande anti hitlérienne incarcéré à
la prison d'orléans il est transféré à
compiègne puis déporté dans un convoi à
auschwitz le résistant portera le
matricule 45 mille quatre cent soixante
dix jusqu'à son décès à birkenau
en août 1942 des souvenirs de son
grand-père
marie paule conserve précieusement ses
rares photos de lui dans un album de
famille wyss et c'est très bon c'est
superbe
submergée d'émotion
marie paule a désormais un ultime
souhait pour que l'action de son grand
père pendant l'occupation nazie ne tombe
pas dans l'oubli
bon je ne suis plus très jeune et je
voudrais vraiment qu un lieu public
porte son nom sur orléans sur ses rangs
ou dans l'agglomération d'orléans avant
vraiment de partir pour toujours les
grands hommes méritent nous dit elle que
l'heure nous reste gravé dans le marbre